[音楽]
[拍手]
伝統工芸って
どうしても守らなきゃいけないんですか
今日はその答えになるような3つのお話をさせていただきます
私の話を聞いて
ちょっとだけ伝統工芸に興味を持ってもらえたらうれしいです
まず1つめの話
それは根付についてです
今きょとんとした人根付ってご存知ですか
つけて日本ではほとんど知られてないんですけど
例えばイギリス
2010年ベストセラーになってその年一番のブックオブザイヤーに輝いているのは
琥珀の女のうさぎっていう
べ付の本欄です
また欧米の美術館博物館などでは日本美術の一番最初に出てくるのが根付だったりし
ます
なぜでしょう
多くの伝統工芸が大陸から入ってきて日本独自の進化を遂げているんですが
根付は数少ない日本独自の伝統工芸なんです
そんな日本を代表する伝統工芸日本人はほとんど知らない
ではに付けのご紹介をしていきましょう私は伊勢根付の職人です
根付ってねこういうふうに着物の帯に引っ掛けて
巾着などを下げるための道具こっちこの上の部分を
根付って言います
私たちはこの中にこの地域で何百年も先人たちが培ってきた技術とか重いとか
祈りとか願いとか
四季を楽しむ心とか思いやる心とか
粋な遊び心とか
いったものをギュッと閉じ込めて
2ヶ月も3ヶ月も一つを手の中で
コツコツコツコツ掘っていきます
でも根付ってそれで終わりじゃないんです
煮付けは
使う人がたくさん触って
ちょっと摩耗して飴色になったよ状態を
根付用語でなれって言うんですけど
そのなれが生まれると
価値が増すんです
使ったほうが価値が高い
言い慣れが出てるねなんて言って価格が上がったりします
昔の日本人は
新しいものじゃなくて
使い込んで言って
個性的になったものの美しさを評価していたんですね
私はこの考え方に作られたんです
新しいものじゃなくて使い込むほど経験を経るほどに価値が増すという考え方
こんなふうに日本の伝統工芸には先人たちから受け継がれてきた
沢山の精神やも一重っていうものが
た
込められているんです
それでは2つ目
伝統工芸についてご紹介します
私は元 nhk のキャスターでした
ものづくりの職人さんを紹介するコーナーを担当していたのでたくさんの職人さん
そして伝統工芸に出会います
その中で先ほどのなれのような伝統工芸に込められた想い背伸知会みたいなものに惹か
れると同時に
もう一つ
て技の素晴らしさに魅かれていくんです
なんで手作りの物ってなくちゃいけないんだろう
例えば皆さん今手元にある紙
これの手作りって
手漉きの和紙です
手漉きの和紙を張った庄司
実は
開いている状態より締めている状態のほうが部屋の中が明るいんだそうです
外の光を取り込む際に
手漉きの和紙が乱反射して部屋の中に光をいっぱい取り込むから部屋の中は明るくなる
んだよって
美濃和紙の職人さんが教えてくれました
もちろん機械で作った髪も大事
でも
好きのは歯がなくなっちゃったら
選択肢がなくなったら
もったいないと思いませんか
そしてもう一つ取材を通じて気がついたこと
当時12年前
ほとんどの伝統工芸に
後継者がいなかった
ほとんどすべてです
これは業界全体に何か問題があるなあって
思っている中で気がついたんです
職人の地位が低いということに
私が取材させていただいた職人さんの中には
取材させていただいてお礼を言いに行った際に
ありがとう
初めて日の目を見たんだよ
初めて近所の人や親戚の人に
素晴らしい仕事をしてたんだね
入ってもらえたんだ
野党
で
私の手を握りながら
泣きながらお礼を言ってくれる職人さんがいました
また他の職人さんは
石入りを希望してくれる人はいても
刑務所を出た人か
障害のある人しかいなかった
もちろん
その人たちが悪いっていうわけではない
でも東大を出た人が
伝統工芸受け継ぎたいって
入って来てくれたっていいじゃないかって訴える人
特に多くの職人さんからはバブルの頃
苦しい思いをしたという職人さんの声をたくさん耳にしました
それを解決するためには
職人自身が発信することが大切だって思ったんです
職人自らが伝統工芸って職人ってこんなにカッコイイって発信できたら
未来は変わるかもしれないのにって思っていろんな職人さん
人間国宝みたいな人たちにお願いに行きます
でも皆さん
それは大事なことだけれども
でも
自分は前に出るのが苦手だから
誰か他の人にやってもらっててへバレちゃうんです
みんなが誰か他の人って言ってたら
何にも変わらないのにってえっ
持って気がついたんです
そうか
誰か他の人にやってもらおうって思ってたのは
もしかして私だったのかなって
それで2010年
伊勢根付の職人にれ c 入りしました
さあ3つ目です3つ目にご紹介したいのは仲間です
伝統工芸の世界に入った私は気がつきました
どうやら伝統工芸の世界に若い人が入ってきてくれたとしても長続きしていないという
現実に
正直伝統工芸を使う人が少なくなった今
若手の職人の生活は大変です
生活がままならなくなって辞めていく人が数多くいました
でも人生を賭けてこの伝統工芸を受け継ぎたいって入って来てくれたこの子たちが
受け付けなかったら
伝統工芸の未来は確実にないんです
どうにかして
入ってきてくれた若い職人たちを守らなければ
そう思って
2012年三重県内の若手職人を集めてグループをつくりました
漆一刀彫型紙根付
6人です当時6人しかいませんでした
正直最初は金銭的にも大変でなかなか活動も思うようにいかず
でもたくさんみんなで夢を語りました
夢を語って色んな人にお願いしていろんな人が助けてくれて
少しずつ夢が叶うようになっていって
去年の秋
大きな目標だった
海外でみんなで活躍したいねという夢がかなうことになります
マレーシア香港ベトナムでみんなでワークショップをさせてもらいました
海外でワークショップをするとそれはそれは大人気
45中にも人が集まってきてコレなにやってるのコレなにどうやって使うのどうする
のってみんな一生懸命聞いてくれます海外で伝統工芸ってこんなに大人気なんだって
本当にみんなで感動しました
大きな大きな私たちの夢がかなった瞬間でした
そして
もう一つ
2017年
東海三県の若手女性職人を集めてグループをつくりました
尾張七宝
伊勢型紙
有松絞り
漆
伊勢根付豊橋筆
伊勢一刀彫伊賀組紐箕輪4-9人です
こちらもまだできたばっかりっていうこともあって正直
資金的に大変です特に東海3県に分かれてしまっているので補助金などをもらえるあて
もなく
一人一人に協賛金という形でお願いして少しずつお金をもらって
リーフレットなどをつくって少しずつ活動を始めています
今月には日本一のデパートで展示販売もできるようになりました
チャットづつちょっとづつ前に進んでいます
私たちのグループには夢があるんです
日本一の伝統工芸のグループになること
日本一になって
私たち自身が自らのて0
伝統工芸って職人ってこんなにかっこいいでしょって言えたら
未来は変わると思うんです
私たちがちゃんと生活できることを背中で示して私たちの背中をみて子回人が伝統工芸
を受け継ぎたいって思ってくれたら
伝統工芸の未来は変えられるんです
私には確信があるんです
初めて三重県に来た13年前伊勢神宮はそんなに観光客の多い観光地ではなかった
でもそれから10年たって今では1千万人を超えるような
たくさんの人が訪れる観光地になりました
各国の首相が訪れたりもしています
伊勢神宮に立って波があるんです
こう客が少ないとき守って来てくれた人がいるから
今こんなにたくさんの人に愛されている
伝統工芸だって同じです
今は数が少ないけど
5年後10年後
たくさんの人に必要とされているかもしれない
今ならまだ間に合う今なくしちゃったらもったいない
そして出しば海外で着物の国際交流親善大使として
海外で賞などに出たりしているんですが着物を出て海外で街中に出るとそれはそれは際
人気
私女優っていうぐらいいろんな人に声をかけてもらって素敵ねって言って写真を撮って
くれたりします
根付の10時に行ってもこれ何言って本当に目をきらきらして皆さんが話を聞いてくれ
ます
伝統工芸まだまだ可能性を秘めているんです
最後になりましたが
伝統工芸を生活の中に取り入れること
それは
日本の風土の中で育まれてきた
先人たちの
4 a 8
重い
精神などを
生活の中に取り込むことでもあります
それは古臭いことかもしれません
でも
どんどんお米化している今
心が苦しくなったとき
重くなったとき
伝統工芸を取り入れたら二戸市
軽くなるかもしれません
未来へのヒントが隠されているかもしれません
伝統工芸を生活の中に取り入れることは
可能性を広げること
伝統工芸使ってみてください
[拍手]